yeah with five minutes on the clock yeah  I've ever seen Magnus through something  like this not since he was like five  years old or saying even then he was  probably losing the pram yeah yeah  throwing Rooks out the door here you go  have a rook so that extra Black Knight  it's it's found loads of uh kind of safe  squares outposts and that's the key if  you can keep it on a safe Square you  will win I think the Rooks kind of come  and take that last Pawn now it's it's  one simple there's many many ways you  can win this but okay Love's trying but  you can take that white porn now yep  bring the black Rook back if you want to  play safe you give a check first yeah  maybe the king can snake its way to the  right stale mate stale Matrix if you  take the pawn  that's true  have a Checkmate the white king trapped  yeah nice Checkmate oh we rarely see  that in chess this is a comeback by  Magnus Carlsen the vulneronian he uh  loses